Mein Vortrag wird sich also um Gynoid und Shilla drehen
und zu Beginn werde ich auf
einige Punkte eingehen, die wir
gestern auch heute in Bezug auf die
Cants-Philosophie gehört haben. Lassen Sie mich daher zunächst
mit einigen Bemerkungen zum Vorkommen
des Worttrips in der deutschen Literatur beginnen
1600 bis zum Jahr 2000, also haben wir diesen
Google Ngram-Viewer, der sehr
hilfreich ist, weil Sie dort einen Höhepunkt
um das Jahr 1800 herum sehen können. Sie sehen, dass
es im Vergleich zu älterer und jüngerer Literatur so viele Vorkommnisse gibt, die
von der Wortreise sprechen
großes Interesse an diesem Thema um
1800, aber ich wollte auch etwas
über das Begriffsfeld des Trips sagen,
denn wie wir gestern gehört haben, gibt
es ähnliche Konzepte um diesen
Begriff des Antriebs, also
haben wir einerseits für Kraft Kraft dann haben
wir  anreiz manchmal wird 3theta mit
anreiz übersetzt dann haben
wir motivation motiv und falsche
absicht ich denke professor überleben
bezog sich auf diesen punkt wir h
In gewisser Weise haben wir Intentionalität, dann haben wir
Streben, wir haben auch Neigung, und wir
haben den Willen, und Spontaneität ist auch ein
Kandidat für Antrieb, es ist nicht dasselbe,
aber es ist im selben Bereich und so weiter,
es könnte auch andere geben, die wir
in dieses Feld einbeziehen könnten  Lassen Sie mich
zunächst mit der Karotten-Konzeption von Trieb
und Antriebskraft beginnen, fitter zu sein, wie ich
übersetzte, und den Begriff aktuellen
Kontext seiner Anthropologie und
Metaphysik des Verbrechens.
Ich werde dann zu Reinhard und der
Dualität der Triebe übergehen.
Ich meine, Professor Verkäufer beziehe mich auf diese
Dualität  Heute
und zum Schluss werde ich Chiles
Trinität der Triebe diskutieren, weil er hier
nicht nur zwei Triebe hat, er kennt drei
Versuche, und ich werde versuchen, die
Beziehung zwischen diesen drei Arten
von Trieben zu analysieren, und ich werde auch auf
neuere Literatur in der Analytik verweisen  Philosophie
und um diese Vorstellungen zu vergleichen ist meine
These, dass wir den philosophischen Triebbegriff besser verstehen können
im
Begriff einer Theorie des Individuums
frei  Dom und Wille der Autonomie in der
Heteronomie Ich denke, dass dieser Begriffskontext
sehr hilfreich ist, um
die Entwicklung des
Triebbegriffs nachzuvollziehen, vielleicht schon vorher, aber
zumindest bei Kant und Afrika und bei
Reinhold und Schiller können wir sie
besser nachvollziehen  Theorien Ihre
Vorstellungen von Antrieb, wenn wir sie
mit den Nachteilen vergleichen. Vorstellung von Trip. Antrieb und
Leapreader-treibende Kraft. In Bezug
auf Can't werden sie also klarer. Lassen Sie
mich mit Can't auf Tipp und Twig Theta beginnen.
Zuerst seine Vorstellung von Drive, also wie
Übersetze Trip Theta Ich beziehe mich auf diese
Frage am Anfang, also gibt es einen
Anreiz, das ist ein Kandidat, es gibt ein
Motiv, es gibt Frühling, manchmal in Bezug
auf die Uhr, und dann gibt es die treibende
Kraft, und ich persönlich bevorzuge die treibende
Kraft, also werde ich im Folgenden
auch immer  Beziehen Sie sich auf einen Trip Theta als
treibende Kraft, es könnte noch andere
Übersetzungen geben, aber ich bevorzuge treibende Kraft,
also verwendet Kant die Begriffe Fahrt, Fahrt und
treibende Kraft  Trip Theta in
verschiedenen Kontexten, besonders wenn es
um den Begriff des Antriebs und der
Anthropologie geht, ist dies besonders
wichtig, also habe ich einige Zitate, einige
Vorkommen des Antriebs, er spricht von dem
Versuch für Wissenschaftsclips von Geschäftswellen,
dann ist dies sicherlich eine
anthropologische Keimung, die wir haben
den Trieb des Ehrgeizes behandeln sie so
airsoft dann in seiner Religion er ich glaube
ein Professor Heidemann hat
in seinem Vortrag gestern darauf hingewiesen wir haben die
britische Position zur Animalität und hier
kann von zwei Trieben gesprochen werden
nämlich sozialer Trieb Trip zu einem
Gazellenschacht und der sexuelle  Drive Trip Einige
reflektieren, das sind natürlich
anthropologische Konzepte des Drives,
dann können wir fragen, was die treibende
Kraft ist, ja, Geld
soll argumentieren can't
entwickelt eine systematische Darstellung der Fahrt, sondern
nur der treibenden Kraft, nicht des
Antriebs ju  st anthropologische Bestimmung
und hat nichts mit seiner
Metaphysik des Willens oder der Moral zu
tun, also spricht er hier sehr allgemein von der
treibenden Kraft als dem inneren
Bestimmungsgrund des Willens und er sagt auch, dass eine
treibende Kraft Twitter der subjektive
Bestimmungsgrund von ist  Unserer Ansicht nach, wenn es
um seine Metaphysik der Moral im
Allgemeinen und seine Autonomie des
Willens geht, wird sein Gebrauch der Triebkraft
systematischer, so dass er hier
vom Unterschied zwischen der
pathologischen Triebkraft und der moralischen
Triebkraft spricht, ähnlich wie er sagt, dass es
die gibt  moralischer oder pathologischer Antrieb
zuerst der Handlungen, so dass er klar
zwischen zwei Arten von
treibenden Kräften unterscheidet, wenn es um Natur
und Heteronomie geht. Kant sagt, dass die
treibende Kraft die treibende Kraft der
Natur
ist  Draußen ist in gewisser Weise alles, was sie sagt, das
Angenehme, da die treibende Kraft der
Wünsche immer dasselbe ist
und der Sangha-Name ist  Drei Twitter
debe geerdon Jüdische Banden aus Inal ir
alles gehört dem gleichen
großen Kerl wenn es nicht Autonomie ist wenn es
Heteronomie ist es könnte verschiedene
Phänomene geben, die zur gleichen
treibenden Kraft der Natur gehören okay dann haben
wir auf der anderen Seite haben wir
Vernunft und unsere Autonomie, wenn es um
diese Unterscheidung zwischen diesen beiden Arten
von treibender Kraft geht, und er kann darüber sprechen, dass er,
wie Sie wissen, in seiner zweiten
Kritik das dritte Kapitel hat, und hoffen, dass Duke
seinen Titel über die treibenden Kräfte der
reinen praktischen Vernunft hat  Eigentlich ist es
nicht die treibende Kraft der reinen praktischen
Vernunft, sondern die treibenden Kräfte der
praktischen Vernunft, also können wir fragen, ob es die
verschiedenen treibenden Kräfte der reinen
praktischen Vernunft sind, wie Sie alle wissen, es ist
das moralische Gefühl des Respekts, aber die
Frage bleibt immer noch die gleiche, warum er
spricht von den treibenden kräften gibt es nicht
nur eine treibende kraft nämlich respekt
also ist das eine große frage glaubt ihr
füße auf der rheinpartie femini  sts und
dann sagt er in der gleichen arbeit in der
zweiten kritik respekt vor dem
moralgesetz ist die seele und auch die unbestrittene
moralische treibende kraft es gibt nur eine
treibende kraft okay das ist die rationalität
das ist die autonomie im vergleich zur heteronomie
und die treibende kraft der natur aber  wie
wir hier sehen können
, hat sich diese Unterscheidung im
Vergleich zu seiner Triebkonzeption etwas weiter entwickelt und
nun kommt eine andere wichtige Konzeption
ins Spiel, nämlich seine Konzeption des
menschlichen Willens, und der menschliche Wille
liegt zwischen diesen beiden treibenden
Kräften in seiner Grundlagenarbeit, sagt er  zitieren
das rad steht zwischen seinen a priori
principales formal und es ist ein pastor i
unser antrieb zu erscheinen, der
materiell ist wie an einer kreuzung und da
es noch von etwas bestimmt werden muss,
muss es von dem moralischen
prinzip des wollens als solchem bestimmt werden, wenn ein
Handlung wird aus Pflicht getan, wo ihr jedes
materielle
Prinzip entzogen wurde, so dass der Wille
genau in der Mitte und ein Teil davon ist  Es ist
die Wahl von Ville Korea, tatsächlich zu
entscheiden, was der bestimmende
Grund meines Willens sein soll, entweder die ehemalige oder
die materielle treibende Kraft, also ist dies
das Bild von in Kürze,
wo Manya es beschrieben hat Krater Ling
und was ich gefunden habe  Interessant war,
dass in Infinitesimalrechnung jede Luke auf
Lexikon trifft Manches bin ich für Aufklärung ein
Stöbern überfülltes
Lexikon für Klimaanlagen ist Lexikon zur leichteren Nutzung des
Landes und Schriften Spätausgabe
1798, dass wir keinen Eintrag zum Konzertkonzept finden werden
fahren gibt es
nur einen Eintrag für Reiseleiter da sieht
man im guten Rhythmus viel Feind und er
unterscheidet wie gejagt zwischen dieser
formalen treibenden Kraft und der materiellen
treibenden Kraft hier das ist das
Material also englische Führer und Können
und hier ist treibende Kraft einer  Grund
der praktische Grund, also fand ich das
sehr interessant, weil er offensichtlich
dachte, dass er das
Konzept des Triebs in seinem Mexiko nicht diskutieren sollte,
also lasst uns mit der Männlichkeit und dem fortfahren
Dualität der Triebe In seinem 7. Brief über
die kantische Philosophie hatte er einen
interessanten Titel, er ist betitelt
über den bisher unerkannten
Unterschied zwischen dem selbstlosen, von mir
ignorierten Mondsucher und dem selbstsüchtigen hohen
Agnostiker, einem Trieb zwischen diesen beiden
Trieben und dem Willen, den wir haben
Unterscheidung zwischen will
selbstsüchtigem Antrieb Ich kann Ritsuko und
selbstlosem Wille entkommen sichere drei, also
wie analysiert er diese Unterscheidung, also
sagt er, dass dies eine sehr wichtige
Unterscheidung ist, sagt er, dass dies ein
Unterschied ist, von dem einmal
alle grundlegenden Lehren zugelassen wurden  und
nachfolgende Klauseln in ihrer Darstellung
ergeben also sozusagen die grundlegende
Schlüsselunterscheidung für seine Philosophie
und es gibt eine interessante Sache, denn
es gibt eine triebtheoretische
Umformulierung des klerikalen
kategorischen Einkommensimperativs, die
Reinhart
im Rahmen seiner zur folgenden fertigen Definition führt
Transformation kommt der Doktrin der
Autonomie, sagt er dazu  ist seine Vorstellung
vom kategorischen Imperativ Trieb
theoretisch erklärt er sagt, in all
deinen Willenshandlungen die Befriedigung oder
Unzufriedenheit deines egoistischen
Dr.p der Forderung des
Uneigennützigen unterzuordnen so versteht Reinhart
den kategorischen Imperativ
in seiner Unterscheidung zwischen  der
egoistische und der uneigennützige trieb also
sieht man das hat mit
dem kantischen begriff des kategorischen
imperativs fast nichts zu tun weil da kein trieb
dabei ist das ist nur ein formales prinzip
ein kategorischer imperativ und hier
scheint mir das ein materielles oder zu sein
Eher eine konkrete Definition, der
Kant meiner Meinung nach nicht zugestimmt hätte,
aber es ist interessant,
und hier ist ein weiteres Zitat, in dem er sagt, dass die
Forderung des egoistischen sowie des
selbstlosen Triebs Vorschriften
sind, die der Person einerseits aus reiner
praktischer Vernunft gegeben werden, andererseits durch
theoretische Vernunft vermittelt durch Lust
und Unlust,
also hier richtig, wie sie die
Unterscheidung zwischen verbindet  Bei diesen Arten von
Trieben zu einer Unterscheidung innerhalb der Vernunft,
also wissen Sie, dass sich der egoistische Trieb
auf eine theoretische Vernunft bezieht,
hypothetische Imperative, was muss
ich tun, um zu diesem Ziel zu gelangen, und
rein praktische Vernunft, die der selbstlose Trieb ist, den
ich gefunden habe  das ist
so interessant, dass er auch er nicht nur
den kategorischen Imperativ in
Bezug auf Triebe analysiert, sondern auch die Kapazität der
Vernunft rein praktischer Vernunft und
Ihre
hypothetische Vernunft sozusagen in Bezug
auf Triebe lediglich empirisch konditioniert, so dass die Unterscheidung von Trieben
im Recht sehr entscheidend wird
Person kann nicht fahren war meiner Meinung nach nur ein
anthropologischer Dist-Begriff, der meiner Meinung nach nicht sehr
systematisch gut ausgearbeitet wurde
, aber wir können darüber diskutieren, damit
es für Irland wirklich wichtig wird,
so dass alles, was er sagt, die Anforderungen der beiden
Triebe des Egoisten und des Uneigennützigen
genannt werden  Triebkräfte
der Willensfreiheit, inwieweit sie sich
an willkürlichen Befriedigungen oder
Unzufriedenheiten beteiligen  Begierde, also verbindet er jetzt
den Begriff des Triebs mit den
treibenden Kräften, also bringt er es dann
zusammen,
was Kant nicht getan hat. Ja, also fand ich
dieses sehr interessante andere Zitat,
die Welt ist in zwei
Teile
geteilt  wo er sagte, dass der
Wille wie an einem Scheideweg steht, so
bezieht sich dieses Zitat auf dieses Zitat,
da ich glaube, er sagt, der Wille sei
in zwei ursprünglich wesentlich
verschiedene und wesentlich vereinte Triebe
aufgeteilt, von denen einer auf
Sinnlichkeit gegründete Lust als Ganzes als Objekt hat
die andere gegenwärtige unpersönliche
Selbstaktivität stellt ein
nur von sich aus notwendiges Gesetz auf dies ist der treibende
Grund in einer triebtheoretischen
Beschreibung was wichtig ist Ich denke,
Professor Sola hat auf diese Tatsache Bezug genommen
Reinhold begreift den Willen nicht
als etwas, das eine niedrigere und eine
höhere Begierde hat  Fakultät, also denkt er,
dass beide Stämme auf der gleichen Ebene sind,
wie er sagt, der egoistische und der
selbstlose Stamm  s sind beides mögliche
motive freiheit zitat die beiden triebe
müssen natürlich in jedem
wollenden valen und unserem vorhanden sein, denn ohne
sie ist der
willen denkbar gute gründe und weil die objekte des willens
durch sie bestimmt werden sind objektive
gründe objektivität unter des willens so
ich  Denke, dass immer Rationalität im
Spiel ist. Ich fand das sehr interessant,
also ist das eine Art Gründe,
Freiheit. Es gibt Passagen bei Reinhardt,
wo man sagen könnte, das ist nur
willkürlich und anders, ja,
bloße Wahl, aber wer von Gründen spricht,
also gibt es einen Grundwolf, den wir
mit denen wir umgehen können, können wir darüber nachdenken, also sind
die Triebe eine Art Gründe oder
Gegenstand der Reflexion von Willy, und dann
fand ich als einen anderen interessanten Punkt,
den ich Reinholds Kompatibilismus nennen werde
, in der Art und Weise, wie er sagt, dass unmoralisches
Handeln absolute praktische Notwendigkeit und
Freiheit vereint  soweit das
unbedingt notwendige Recht, dh die Wirkung
der praktischen Vernunft,
im Einzelfall und dann durch Wahl ausgeübt wird  Die bisher
gemachte Wirkung der Freiheit im
sittenlosen Handeln sind Naturnotwendigkeit und
Freiheit insofern vereint, als
die nur
den Naturgesetzen der Begierde gemäße, aber
praktisch dem Gesetz widersprechende Selbstverständlichkeitsforderung
des eigensüchtigen Triebes willkürlich verwirklicht wird  und nicht so weit
auf die Wir-Wirkung erhoben, so versucht er,
die Notwendigkeit des Sittengesetzes
in gewisser Weise zusammenzubringen, den Zwang des Sittengesetzes
und die Notwendigkeit dessen, was Kant
den natürlichen Antrieb nennt, und er sagt,
dass beides  Triebkräfte sind
mit Freiheit vereinbar, also ist es nicht nur so,
dass wir in der Bestimmung von uns zum Beispiel
durch die Bestimmung durch die Triebkraft der
Natur ein heteronom
bestimmtes Nein sein sollten, es besteht die Möglichkeit
, sie mit der Freiheit zu
vereinbaren, die ich fand  sehr interessant
Ich werde auf Sheila und die Trinität
der Stämme eingehen, so dass sich Sheila bereits in seiner Dissertation
von 1780 über die Gesamtkultur in
Stuttgart mit dem
Konzept befasste  so war sein Ziel,
in dieser Dissertation eine Geschichte des Individuums zu geben
und zu analysieren, wie sich all seine geistigen
Fähigkeiten aus zentralen Trieben entwickelten
Ich fand das interessant, weil es
sehr früh war und nun seine ästhetischen Buchstaben
den menschlichen Willen teilen  zuerst in zwei
triebe das erschöpft den begriff der
menschheit zuerst haben wir den stofflichen
trieb gestopft sprung und er beschreibt
es wie folgt in diesem begriffszusammenhang
verstehen wir nichts anderes als
änderung oder realität die zeit in
Anspruch nimmt folglich verlangt dieser trieb dass
es da sein soll  geändert, dass die zeit
inhalt haben soll, andererseits
gibt es eine andere triebform triebform
trip, die sie wie folgt beschreibt:
die form treibt will, dass das reale
notwendig und ewig ist und das
ewige notwendig und notwendig, um real zu sein,
also sind sie drin  Ein Weg, der sich gegenseitig ergänzt,
aber sie sind nicht die einzigen Laufwerke,
wie ich zuvor sagte, es gibt eine Trinität von
Stämmen, und hier gibt Jilla eine  Art der
Begründung für die Einführung seiner
Triebkonzepte sagt er Zitat
Ich zögere nicht, diesen Begriff
nämlich Trieb zusammenfassend sowohl für das zu verwenden, was
die Einhaltung eines Gesetzes verfolgt, den
Formtrieb, als auch für das, was danach strebt,
den materiellen Trieb zu befriedigen und zu benötigen, obwohl
man ihn sonst braucht  tendiert dazu, es nur
auf den Buchstaben zu beschränken, so wie rationale Ideen
zu Imperativen oder Pflichten werden, sobald
sie in die Grenzen der
Zeit gestellt werden, so werden diese Pflichten zu Impulsen,
sobald sie sich auf etwas
Bestimmtes und Wirkliches beziehen, entsteht dieser Trieb nur der
Formtrieb  notwendigerweise und
fehlt demjenigen nicht, der dagegen handelt,
ohne dass es keinen moralisch
bösen und folglich auch keinen moralisch guten
Willen gäbe, also sind beide Triebe
auch im bösen Handeln schon immer enthalten, also geht es
nur darum, dass wir ein ähnliches
Fremdkönnen finden.  Die
Unterordnung von Maximen ist ziemlich
interessant, aber von Maximen sind nicht
Triebe, und hier ist für Shilla wichtig,
dass beide Triebe es nicht sind
getrennt er sagt, dass sie
sich aufeinander beziehen müssen sie sich
gegenseitig in einem
unterordnungsverhältnis stehen müssen zitieren beide prinzipien sind
das untergeordnete und aufeinander
abgestimmt gleichzeitig esse ich sie stehen
in zusammenwirkung ohne form
gibt es keine materie ohne materie gibt
es  Keine Form, das ist eine komplementäre
Auffassung der Triebe
und gegenüber Reinhard, der eine eher
statische Vorstellung von diesen Trieben hatte, hat
Schiller eine genetische, die ich eine
Evolutionstheorie der Freiheit nennen möchte,
die auf seiner Unterscheidung der Triebe basiert,
sagt er die sinnliche  Der Trieb erwacht mit
der Lebenserfahrung mit dem
Beginn des Individuums der Vernünftige
mit der Erfahrung des Gesetzes mit dem
Beginn der Persönlichkeit und nun
erst nachdem erst nachdem beides
entstanden ist seiner Menschlichkeit zuzuordnen
Horizont hat auch er einen anderen Akkord in sich
Im Vordergrund des sinnlichen
Triebes steht die Einsicht in die ganze Freiheitsgeschichte des Menschen erst dort, wo die Freiheit beginnt  Wenn der Mensch vollständig ist und seine zwei
Grundtriebe entwickelt haben, ist dies ein genetisches
Modell der menschlichen Freiheit, das
durch seine Triebkonzeption ermöglicht wird.
Hier finden wir eine Gerechtigkeit und Ausbeutung,
wir finden eine Art Kritik an
Kants Transzendentalphilosophie, die
mich ein wenig erinnert  von Hegel sagt er Sheila
Gott, in einer transzendentalen Philosophie, in der
alles darauf ankommt, die
Form von ihrem Inhalt zu befreien und das
Notwendige von allem Zufälligen rein zu halten, ist
es sogar leicht, sich daran zu gewöhnen
, das Material nur als
Hindernis zu betrachten und sich darin zu präsentieren  Sinnlichkeit,
weil sie diesem
Geschäft in einem unvermeidlichen Widerspruch
zur Vernunft im Wege steht, so heißt es, beides muss
koordiniert werden, das eine kann nicht
ohne das andere sein, sie sind irgendwie miteinander verflochten
, und schließlich müssen wir es
falsch spielen und hier das  Es stellt sich die Frage, welche
Rolle es spielt, als Sheila sagte, dass
sowohl der Materialtrieb als auch der
Formtrieb die menschliche Natur erschöpfen, also warum
sollte es da sein  Es wird ein anderer Antrieb sein,
es ist ein zusätzlicher Antrieb, ich glaube nicht,
dass der Antrieb sowohl aus
dem Material als auch aus dem Sinn der Form
hervorgeht  Der Geist kann
gleichzeitig moralisch und
physisch booten, da er alle
Kontingente zum Füllen seiner Karte abgeschafft hat, wird er auch
die ununterstützte Notwendigkeit abschaffen und den
Menschen sowohl physisch als auch moralisch befreien.
Dies ist also eine Art negativer Freiheit, die
wir auf der einen Seite haben  wir haben die
körperliche Notwendigkeit ssin durch den materiellen
Trieb und dann haben wir die sozusagen
rationale Bestimmung durch den Formtrieb,
und dies ist nicht der einzige Status
, in den der Spieltrieb
den Menschen versetzt, denn hier
betont Schiller die Harmonie des Willens  sagt
zitat es ist als spielautokino ein zustand
höchster
realität anzusehen, wenn man
auf die abwesenheit aller
barrieren und auf die summe der kräfte
entsprechend achtet  gemeinsam handeln
sie alle wissen, dass dies eine sehr berühmte Passage
ist, in der er sagt, dass der Mensch hier nur spielt, wenn er
im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes ein
Mensch ist, und er ist nur dann ein vollständiger Mensch,
wenn er spielt. Was müssen wir also unter
Spielen verstehen?  Es ist nicht nur
Glücksspiel. Ich denke, die englische Sprache
hat mehr Ausdrücke für Stahl kann ein
Spiel sein
ein
Fußballspiel, weil es
einerseits Regeln gibt, also ist es nicht nur
etwas Willkürliches, es gibt Regeln in einem
Spiel, und andererseits
gibt es eine Art Freiheit, diese Regeln zu füllen
oder im Rahmen
dieser Regeln zu handeln I  Denke, das ist es, was
Shilla im Sinn hat. Freiheit braucht
Regeln, Einschränkungen, bestimmte
Bestimmungen und einige
Kontingente, einige, um den Kite zu beenden und
beides zusammenzubringen, macht und
befreit uns
auch in diesem Zitat hier  Oben
sagt er, Spiel sei keine Einschränkung, sondern
eine Erweiterung des lebenswichtigen Krankenhauses des Menschen.
Wie ich bereits sagte, ist Freiheit ein sehr
entscheidender Begriff, wenn es um Sheilas und
Reynolds Unterscheidung dieser
Triebe geht. Sheila sagt, im Spiel seien sowohl der
materielle Zwang als auch die Gesetze von  Natur
und der spirituelle Zwang
der Moralgesetze sind in einem
höheren Begriff der Notwendigkeit getrennt, aus dem
wahre Freiheit hervorgeht, also denke ich, dass der
Spieltrieb nichts Zusätzliches ist, es ist
keine Fähigkeit, so etwas nicht
auf der gleichen ontologischen Ebene wie der
Teller  dann der Formtrieb und der
Stofftrieb, sondern es ist vielmehr das
Produkt ihres Zusammenwirkens, es entsteht,
wenn beide Triebe Grundtriebe oder Triebe
erster Ordnung in einem sehr
harmonischen Zustand sind und bei dieser
Harmonie erster Ordnung wie oft eine zweite
Ordnung entsteht und diese zweite
Ordnungstrieb ist das, was Sheila den Spieltrieb nennt
, also ist es eine andere ontologische
Ebene, die nicht auf dieser grundlegenden Ebene erster Ordnung
liegt, die ich interpretieren würde.  Es ist also
nicht auf der gleichen Ebene, es ist etwas
, das aus der ersten Ordnung der
Triebe hervorgeht, und er sagt, wie ich schon sagte, ihre
Freiheit entsteht, und er beschreibt diese
Art von Freiheit als eine Notwendigkeit, ein höheres
Konzept der Notwendigkeit, wir finden auch dieses
Konzept von a  höhere Notwendigkeit und
Schelling, wie wir später vielleicht hören werden, also denke ich
, dass sich das Teilen, dass Sheila die
Herausforderung an dieser Stelle auf Sheila bezogen haben könnte,
und es gibt nicht nur
Shelling, der das interessant fand,
weil Sheila in seinen Callias sagte,
es gibt einen interessanten Begriff, nämlich er
schrieb er  Autonomie versus Autonomie
sagt er in diesen Karrieren, als ob das Perfekte
Autonomie haben kann, insofern seine
Form rein durch seinen
Begriff bestimmt wurde, aber ihre Autonomie hat nur das
Schöne, weil nur hier die
Form vom inneren Wesen bestimmt wird, also denke ich
, das
seine  Konzeption des Spieltriebs ermöglicht es
Schiller, eine Konzeption
individueller Selbstbestimmung individueller
Autonomie zu entwickeln, so dass sich ein Individuum
nicht selbst hingibt  ein allgemeines gesetz sondern ein
individuelles gesetz das nur für
ihn gilt im gegensatz zum allgemeinen
vermögen der reinen praktischen vernunft dessen
autonomie ich denke das ist eine art
individueller selbstbestimmung und wie ich
schon gesagt habe freiheit als eine höhere art
von höherer notwendigkeit ist  Auch prominent in
neueren Freiheitstheorien, zum
Beispiel Harry Frankfurt, ich meine, er ist
schon 25 Jahre alt, aber er sagt immer noch, ich
glaube, dass die wahrhaftigste Freiheit
nicht nur mit einem Attentat vereinbar ist
, wie es vermuten lässt, dass es tatsächlich
eine Notwendigkeit erfordert, die
ich nicht teile  aber diese
Autonomie besteht im Wesentlichen und
ausschließlich darin, sich den
Anforderungen der Pflicht zu unterwerfen. Meiner Meinung nach können Handlungen
autonom sein, ob sie pflichtgemäß sind oder nicht,
hier ist die
Frage, ob dies eine korrekte
Interpretation von kann ist, aber ich denke, es geht
in die gleiche Richtung wie Schiller
Da gibt es ein weiteres Zitat, das diese
Zwänge aus
gewollter oder höherer Notwendigkeit argumentieren lässt  nicht
durch konzeptionelle oder logische
Analyse bestimmt werden sie sind eher inhaltlich
als nur formal sie beziehen sich auf die
Zwecke die Vorlieben und die anderen
persönlichen Merkmale, die das
Individuum nicht umhin kann zu haben und die
effektiv die Aktivitäten
seines Willens bestimmt haben, also denke ich, was Ryan und
Schiller  versucht, einen
individuelleren Freiheitsbegriff zu entwickeln, der dann möglich
ist, auf der anderen Seite
könnten sie Probleme haben, für eine
objektive Theorie der Moral zu argumentieren, weil
sie sich nur auf das Individuum konzentrieren,
so dass sie bestimmte Vorzüge verlieren, die sie
steuern können  Meine Meinung, aber wenn es
um die mittlere Freiheit geht, denke ich, dass
sowohl Recht
als auch Sheila immer noch von Bedeutung sind, wenn
Sie sehen, dass sich auch Harry Frankfort in seiner
gleichen siehe meine kompatible istische Theorie
auf eine solche Vorstellung von höherer Notwendigkeit bezieht.
Okay, vielen Dank